if you're dating someone interviewing a
new friend interviewing a new co-worker
this is a test that helps you figure out
sort of who someone is on a subconscious
level so the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm nervous I'm you should be okay I'm
gonna ask you your favorite animal
don't say Henry don't say your dog cuz
that's where I want to do I want to say
my dog I I want to say my dog I want to
say my horse your favorite animal the
one that you admire wolf that's a great
one and three characteristics about a
wolf hmm why you like them um I like
them cuz they're strong who's they're
fast
uh-huh and I like them cuz they travel
in packs I like a buddy system I love
okay
that's genius the second thing is your
favorite article of clothing and it
doesn't have to be something you're
wearing I was like oh like a ball gown
is it a pair of socks I end up doing a
hoodie because they're like classic yeah
they're warm they're sort of
gender-neutral I like that like what
would be your favorite article of
clothing jeans jeans yeah they are Jared
well there were minor stretch
[Laughter]
mine are very stretchy those pregnancy
lady you know what we're the ones
pregnant I thought about it afterwards
but I was like this is too much you
should stop eating and work out blog
with the tie the tie around the top no
no I like regular Joe I like regular
jeans I'm a jeans girl but I like them
because they are there they kind of
they're like second skin yeah I like
that and I'm classic I'm a mom and I'm
running around all the time and then we
have a ranch Montana so you really don't
wear ball gowns in Montana
uh it's a little weird and then your
favorite body of water it can be a
swimming pool a river a lake I suppose I
picked the new River in West Virginia
because I used to spend time there as a
kid
I would I would say rivers why named my
daughter River so I better like it
characteristics of a river I picked that
too so I like that they connect all
bodies of water I've heard yeah they're
connected sometimes they're like rough
sometimes they're not like but I like a
rushing river I like to hear the sound I
like the sound of it it's calming okay
you know and I'm gonna tell you what all
of this means so hey I am ready it's not
that bad okay your favorite animal is
how you see yourself
oh yes what was it strong sound a travel
impact and your favorite article of
clothing reveals how other people
perceive you Owens
yes very comfortable with herself may be
far too comfortable does he come and
then your favorite body of water is how
you view sex yeah you know what it works
I like the sound - next I like it
we're connect so next whole thing I love
river I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this